[Music]
we start because the suit is not a suit if
it is not a bullfighting dress it is called a
light dress the bullfighting dress if you carry it in your
hand is heavy the dress can be
understood only and exclusively when
you have an animal in front of you that has 600
kilos  and it's for you,
oh
well, first of all I'm going to introduce myself as
Antonio López Fuerte, I'm the director
of Casa Fermín, it's been open for 55 years
serving this very select public
[Music]
My mother was an embroiderer for bullfighters and my
brother was a tailor for bullfighters and
So, for your turn when they have
to leave, it's your turn to be a
bullfighter.
The dress begins with treating the client,
observing what the client wants, choosing
the color and then we move on to the
embroidery.
The colors have a meaning, it
depends on the bullfighter.  You are very young, they
usually wear light colors, if you are
brave, you are not an artist, because
you usually wear strong colors, such as
scarlet, many times because of
how striking it is to the eye.
valor and art do not go together there are very
few in the world whose art
exceeds their courage
[Music]
you have to tear up a lot of paper you have to
destroy a lot until the drawing is done,
this all takes time
[Music]
about a dress  In
normal time, using approximately 7
people, it takes a month to do it. It is
a very beautiful profession, especially what
you work on, you see it put in the square and
many times it shines because art shines at
all times, both what you do and what you
do with it.